and pokes it away going up top off the
glass
subs throws it down into the night
in transition the zags ayahi sets up his
point guard for a two-handed jam
pretty all gonzaga
almost gets a straight screen from days
and then takes it he's missed
cam thomas i mean he
drives homes back gets a little
separation
couldn't get it back the other way
[Music]
just above the ramp for one of the best
plays of the night
and it's a spectacular play lucas never
got above the rim he ended up on the
ground
but the ball did it got above the rim
and in the basket
point guard injured yes who stepped into
that spot he's been brilliant
brody goes to work man denied by mobley
brony gets it back tonight again
two bucks for evan mobley all right
gives up a little lbs but he makes it up
for
the long arms and great timing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
once again the ability to elevate
seriously
yep are you as you would say seriously
[Applause]
are you kidding me that'd be one guy
you're trying to get going
another steal ayahi this time pokes it
away going up top
off the glass suggs throws it down
into the night in transition the zags
ayahi sets up his point guard for a
two-handed jam
pretty all gonzaga
pac-12 standing up top oh inbounds
play after the foul miller with that
47-inch vertical
up there in the rafter to the inbounds
play out of bounds not a lot of pressure
on the ball
easy pass but you see the athleticism
that makes isaiah miller special at what
he does
[Music]
he is quick with a jump shot like that
it makes it tough
oh my goodness
the att 5g takes us above the rim for
one of the best plays of the night city
that was beautiful through contact
but i love that was big the big pass
they'll reset sasser giroux with 27
seconds
giro hanging missed it
oh my goodness and houston can take the
lead
was basically basically comes down to
jerome's hard work getting down the lane
and then you see mark finishing it off
but then before that you have three
poor possession by rutgers as they tried
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the big 12 23-2 here they go
it almost looked like vinyl was in slow
motion
he was in the air so long